und während union wir sprachen schon
drüber und spd überlegen wer sie
eigentlich sind und wenn ja wie viele
sind zumindest begrünt für den moment
frei von sinnkrisen der grüne parteitag
von bielefeld am letzten wochenende
quasi ein fest der harmonie montag
annalena baerbock und robert habeck als
vorsitzende bestätigt mit 97 und 90
prozent
warum weil sie die sprache der einfachen
menschen sprechen
der rover zum beispiel findet die grünen
haben eine völlig neue form geschaffen
die eine quasi osmotische verbindung zur
wirklichkeit herstellt wo die
progressiven kräfte reihen diffundieren
können in die parteien wie die energie
aufnehmen können wir aber gleichwohl wie
durch eine membran getrennt sind
[Applaus]
geil oder irgend sowas höre krieg direkt
gänsehaut auf meiner osmotischen
membranen meine damen und herren der
gute laune parteitag der grünen kein
einziger farbbeutel ist diesmal geflogen
dafür gab es allerlei kessen schabernack
schauen sie mal hier der hofreiter toni
flucht
ja süß
danach hat er noch claudia roth die nase
geklaut ja man muss dabei gewesen sei
wirklich überall nur noch friede freude
dinkel kuchen so ein schöner parteitag
so ein schöner parteitag oder alle
[Musik]
wenn du grüner bist dann klatsche in die
hand wenn du schreiten willst dann halt
einfach den rand mensch wir freuen uns
alle so scheint die sonne aus den
brüdern ist dann klatsche in die hand
[Applaus]
durch liegt zu hause ich habe dinge
nicht gesagt dass sie mit klatschen soll
ich konnte nur nicht verhindern ingo
robert marx 1 klatsche in die hand
[Applaus]
langsam macht mir angst so aber fassen
wir zusammen eine warme welle der
harmonie und der einigkeit haben wir da
gesehen bei den grünen im grunde ja wie
sonst nur beim chinesischen
volkskongress das war schon toll es war
toll
klar in der realität gebe es auch was zu
streiten für die man könnte fragen warum
in baden württemberg wo die grünen
regieren den ministerpräsidenten stellen
im ersten halbjahr genau ein windrad
gebaut wurde gibt es dagegen nicht was
von ratiopharm
ich hoffe doch warum nächste frage warum
sind frau baerbock und die brandenburger
grünen mit der 1000 meter abstandsregel
für windräder sogar in den wahlkampf
gezogen lauter gute fragen aber
wenigstens gibt es noch grüne die
stricken das hier ist mein klima schaden
hat eine sehr gute freundin von mir
gestrickt und das sind die abweichungen
von der globalen mitteltemperatur und
hier ist 58 und da ist 2018
ja
da hat meine freundin seit 850
angesteckt
ja ist selbstverständlich sind gut
gemacht sind das wichtigste
ein echtes konfliktthema hätte es geben
können und dieses konfliktthema konnte
die parteien bielefeld gerade noch im
keim ersticken
homöopathie globuli jaja da hatten
nämlich junge grüne den antrag gestellt
homöopathische medikamente nicht mehr
von der krankenkasse zu erstatten
an sich kann man darüber reden reaktion
ein gewaltiger shitstorm der grünen
homöopathie fans also hat die
parteispitze im namen der harmonie das
thema komplett von der tagesordnung für
bielefeld gestrichen
so jetzt zu irgend einen arbeitskreis
diskutieren man will sich halt nicht
verderben mit leuten wie ihr hier hatte
ich glaube der denkfehler ist zu glauben
medizin wäre wissenschaft medizin ist
keine wissenschaft das ist eine
erfahrungsheilkunde er muss im
hintergrund sogar der vogel lachen
natürlich sage wissenschaft es gibt
keine alternativmedizin es gibt ja auch
keine alternativ physik oder alternativ
chemie ja es praktizieren auch sehr gute
heilpraktiker und viele nehmen sich mehr
zeit für den patienten alles richtig
problematisch ist wenn mit mitteln der
allgemeinheit so eine art aberglaube
finanziert wird 20 millionen erstatten
die krankenkassen jedes jahr für
homöopathische medikamente und in bayern
finanziert die staatsregierung jetzt
eine studie die unter anderem erforschen
soll
ob man mit globuli antibiotika ersetzen
kann ist ausdrücklich kein witz die
bayerischen grünen haben dem zugestimmt
wir schalten wir live nach münchen ins
uri geller institut für angewandte
mumpitz wo der heilpraktiker dennis
knossalla bereits an der studie arbeitet
der knossalla globuli statt antibiotika
ist das denn ihr ernst
ja natürlich wir forschen hier auf
hochtouren
das hier zb ist eine handschlaufe aus
der münchner u-bahn seit jahren nicht
gereicht so und daran lasse ich mich
meine probanden zunächst mehrere stunden
intention
infektionen zu ermöglichen er hat
dadurch eine dicke erkältung
mittelohrentzündung wenn dann geht es um
wegs infekt und ebola so global wie man
sieht homöopathie hat keine wirkung die
über den placebo-effekt hinausgeht das
ist doch alles längst wissenschaftlich
geklärt das wäre schon den begriff
wissenschaft ab da steckt das hässliche
wort wissen im gegensatz zur
schulmedizin tun wir heilpraktiker eben
nicht so als wäre alles wissen ich sagen
ja auch nicht globuli helfen gegen alles
gestern zum beispiel haben wir hinten im
hof einen probanden einfach mal
überfahren und da hat sich rausgestellt
dagegen helfen globuli gar nicht wie ich
die erste der zugibt ja das war quatsch
dann hätten wir nicht überfahren soll
aber ich lasse mir trotzdem meinen beruf
nicht schlecht reden um in deutschland
staatlich geprüfte heilpraktiker zu
werden muss man beim gesundheitsamt
einen 13 seitigen malte bild choice test
ausfüllen plus mündliche prüfung wie
jetzt das ist alles sie haben nicht
studiert ohne schulabschluss
wir suchen kreative heiler in berlin zum
beispiel arbeitet ein toller kollege der
hilft hiv-infizierten mit einer hoch
aggressive chlorverbindung eigentlich
ein desinfektionsmittel ist ja kein
medikament in dem see the world league
verortet werden muss das ist frei
verkäuflich das man nicht als medikament
zur einnahme wir sind da der das kauft
kann das verbänden und wer will der kann
zu wasser pilzinfektion einsätzen zum
fensterputzen raten vergiften oder eben
das ist ja das tolle im gegensatz zur
wissenschaft sind wir noch offen für
neue ideen
jede kleine würstchenbude wird in
deutschland total reguliert und
kontrolliert aber heilpraktiker dürfen
fast alles und jetzt sollen global ich
auch noch antibiotika ersetzen
sie sind so brainwash von big pharma ihr
nennt es aber glaube wir nennen es
ganzheitliches denken und wir stellen
einfach mal unverbindliche fragen zb
hilft aderlass wirklich gegen impotenz
wohl nicht hilft ist eigentlich gegen
masern wenn ich bei vollmond eine katze
opfere
und noch wichtiger sind rothaarige
frauen wirklich hexen auf jeden fall
dennis klostermann michael beschreibt
auf facebook wilke du bist der letzte
arsch nur große fresse ich möchte ich
mal sehen wenn es hart auf hart kommt
dann schaust du dir in die hose warte ab
ein sprichwort sagt man trifft sich
immer zweimal im leben
mach weiter so mit einer großen fresse
wie können warten
sehr geehrter herr b man sieht sich im
leben nicht nur zweimal sondern jeden
freitag um 22.30 in zweiter oder hier
auf youtube wenn sie uns abonnieren